welcome back to glamour unfiltered
hosted by me Josh Smith and today we're
joined by the oscar-winning queen of
drama herself Alicia vikander how are
you I'm very good
that's just deep dive into earthquake
bird which is three month at fix right
now because one of the things about this
film is it's about like physical
earthquakes and light but also
earthquakes in people's lives right and
the smaller and bigger ones what has
been like something that's happened to
you that's really shaped you as a person
a big thing would be and that's kind of
the opposite but it felt like that it
was quitting ballet was it why because I
had I was 18 19 years old and you know I
started like dancing when I was three I
got into the Royal Swedish ballet school
and I was nine and you know I go I went
to school six days a week and trained
for I don't know between five and seven
hours a day for nine years and that
becomes kind of part of you and you kind
of grow up with it and London one day I
was started to wonder if it was the
thing and to realize that at that age
around nineteen it's so much other
things you're trying to work out I
remember when I had to go to my coach
and tell them that I maybe think I'm not
gonna dance mmm it's like these people
have invested like actually nine years
to get me to go and do this one and like
you know that was that was you know a
very pivotal point in my life you know
it was kind of the revert of stepping
away from something but it really really
did affect me a lot how does it shape
you I think it shaped me that I dared to
listen that was kind of on this set path
with my obligations or ideas of my own
guilt that I would have even telling my
parents and when I actually did I mean I
had it's a bit like loosing the ideas
that in the end of the film she has a
moment when she shares her her kind of
guilt and realized that you know other
people can share their experiences by
doing that it gets easier and I think
that's what I had done I had created
this like terrific
moment of letting people down once there
was my of course my life and my decision
in that way I think it shaped me knowing
that when it actually happened and when
I had to speak up people said it's okay
you know it's fine
and then you better not regret it
yes she's got the Oscar to prove it
there's no need to regret that decision
whatsoever because it's what like that's
such an amazing thing to say about
trusting your inner voice as well
because it's such a brave thing today in
your career is there a time when you've
really trusted your inner voice and
you've spoken up for your inner voice
that you can recall you know when out
yeah it's been a lot of you know
discussion I heard about just now that
it's special coaches that husband and
she's introduced for intimate scenes in
films I just learned about it yeah today
and that is one thing I was like great I
haven't you know had one of those on set
but that sounds quite especially when
you're kind of in the beginning of your
career and and you feel like you want
you know you want to please in the sense
that you want to do you work right
thank God I think I had you know bit of
an inner compass and maybe women those
seen around me or men and men and I you
know remember when we it's kind of
become because those things are so
tricky to film and it kind of became
like a thing in the beginning that I I
tried to do one take each and that means
that everyone's like aware of what's
going on and it's a little choreographed
and it's done that was of course tricky
in the beginning to feel like you of
course you didn't I mean I should have
but it was a moment when you were afraid
can I can I actually raise my voice mail
hmm then you did yeah no I which is such
a powerful thing to do yeah Wow
no she's such a complex character like
she's got a lot going on in that psyche
what was that like for you to unpack
that and what did it teach you about
yourself that character you know if I
learned anything apart from the Japanese
I would say that you know it is very
much a story about how can you kind of
get past you know traumatic experiences
or sections in your life when you want
to you know move on and she
maybe has an idea but reinventing
herself the question in the end is do
you have to do that or do you just need
to be able to get to know your true self
what's your journey with discovering
your true self and yourself identity
been like for you I was thinking about
that working in another language and
about Lucy moving to Japan when I
started to work I did first few films in
Swedish and then one in Danish actually
in them I about eight nine years ago
came here and did my first
english-speaking film that was part of
kind of getting to know myself in a new
culture and a new language and my
English wasn't like you know that good
in the beginning people especially don't
speak two languages that's great you
know it's like you I was like no cuz I
think about what I say all the time
which means that I turn out to be super
quiet or like I look very serious
because like in here is so much going on
and you know so so it wasn't written
that was kind of a reinventing yourself
trying to find yourself in a new culture
and language because your dad's a
psychiatrist right yes does that is that
something you've like tapped into and
it's made you more introspective in that
sense the cool thing is a lot of people
you know when you have a dad who's that
who's that
so how was that growing you happened
yeah you know did he like you know
analyze you and and I was like and I
thought no and then I realized you know
later on how you know good because if
there's anything he's just so good at
letting other people talking he's sort
of such a good listener and when it
comes to under script I mean he read it
he my parents always read my things and
you know led to a lot of you know
interesting conversations he he also did
come to to set in Japan on this one and
suddenly I had two people from the crew
say oh this guy I think he said one of
the producers had flown over so I start
chatting with him for three hours like
I've told him like my life nothing oh
that's my dad so he only has yeah hmm
he's good at it he's good a gets out the
juice what amazing things about this is
the gap between perception and reality
and I love the fact that you're not on
social media and it because that's like
one of the amazing things about
perception of reality and that's like
such like I don't think like seeing in
the moment is that one of the reasons
why you take a step back from it public
clay it's more become other people's
like what is the reason why do you know
Connor social mean it was very you know
like a simple thing is that I didn't
really feel like I knew why I would do
it
you know yeah and then I kind of like oh
well I don't I'm gonna wait a bit and
then I wait and it was fine and and and
you know if I would ever feel like doing
it I understand it's an amazing way to
communicate or you know the side effect
which is kind of a good one it was like
is there I mean people who I can't can't
follow or can't see that much on you
know out there and get the idea of then
of course I'm easily fooled when I go
and watch their work yeah you know where
I was at oh I feel unrealistic
which is amazing thing to have and you
were incredible thank you so much
joining us and babe you're making it
rain again bringing that drama where we
need it thank you so much thank you so
much
[Music]